yeah welcome to this video a 15 minute
game and yeah aha okay he actually
decides to play move so what should I
plane mmm let's play something else I
rarely play this and none in any form of
chess but then let's see what what
happens kind of modern pills defense
depends them on what do I turn chooses
now aha please see 3 yeah this is a very
solid approach not a bad one by any
means it's just very very solid so what
should I play now gam normal would be
here something like d6 could also think
about playing for d5 likessee 65 or d5
immediately and it's d5 immediately a
bad move I'm really inventing this
opening as I go along here don't know d
5 maybe it's not so bad come on why not
let's try this and for him after all he
has played c3 so CD 525 should be a type
of from Scandinavian a center counter
defense wear white has played in only
see three and it shouldn't be too bad
and if he if he advances then I can play
c5 in one go and this is some other
lines with the similar structure you
opener you're often I've played yeah now
this you often have played c6 unplayed
c5 later
so I'm I have fun maybe maybe save the
tempo am NOT not sure okay so is he
threatening now to take on c5 in case
let's say I play 96 mmm yeah White has
nothing developed really I don't think
Ethan's threatening this he takes on c5
I can even think about f6 breaking up
this pawns and maybe he needs to take
then and then Knight f6 I've got down
like three pieces out and he's got
nothing uh-huh it still does it yeah I'm
not one hundred percent sure but let's
say f6 now and when there's two
possibilities now he lets me take on e5
or he takes himself and then after
Knight f6 I've got two nights our and
the bishop on g7 I mean this is 310 p or
three temples not sure my own english
tempos probably campy yeah while I'm
nicely developed if he takes maybe you
can play that something like Bishop b5
so that I take here takes and then
Bishop b5 we can play Knight f3 catching
up in development I'm not sure that I
would take the pawn instantly maybe I
found some alternatives evil
yeah timeout hmm yeah I think we should
be five it looks some it looks more
sensible to me compared to taking on now
unknown on f6 getting a little bit of
pieces developed takes Knight f6 okay so
Knight f6 right there's nothing yeah
okay okay are nicely developed its own
it should be ok so how to continue now
it's not easy I can cancel first of
course I can always play quickly I
deform the checking the c5 point trying
to get it back I can can really open up
the position with with a move like a
five either now arm or next move by five
would be of course a very sharp move not
not sure at all
and let's say castle first I think if
I've without canceling it looks very
strange so let's castle first now it's
really matter what what is playing on
some moves I might be able to play you
five should be too yeah this is some in
the more conservative option it should
be three hours also possibility so what
now no if I play 90 form just the simple
way to dirty my player should be three
and covering covering the pawn what else
is there I could play b6 making a real
gambit out of this taking queen bee six
that he cannot cancel suddenly I'm
interesting should be some compensation
not sure if enough foods did some
compensation on b6 however he can play
Bishop e3 but after that I've got 94 hmm
alright so v6 is interesting that's one
possibility i have e five also but on 95
it's not quite clear how i continue you
can take every 94 okay but not if i 95
for threatening queen age for this is
not bad at all okay let's say it takes
with the pawn if I've ever takes five
then Knight g4 probably castles 95 and
yeah it's certainly not a bad position
yeah I don't know how to tell okay I'll
go for this for the seven real gambit
that I mentioned the form the only
slight issue is after after he takes on
b6 Queen B 6 i'm not i cannot remove
this knight on f6 so freely because d5
is hanging with check so i need to be
cautious with this but anything I think
Bishop e3 Knight g4 should be really
fine this looks am this looks we're
really wrong for white on sam bishop
moves let's say we would move the bishop
2gy can take f4 and i don't see really
am what's what's the problem where I
don't think he has much choice then
taking them taking this pawn v6
young autumn how to think of anything
else yeah if he ignores this like
castling I would really just take and
have a good Center and f4 as some simply
move that doesn't really fit into the
position of course this is that applies
to 22 any any position now f4 he would
really like to don't don't have this
porn on a form it's really weakening the
old position the own thing that that
it's doing is it's a controlling me five
so that cannot play you five easily yeah
it's not moving it's there something
entirely different I don't see it okay
he went for this which I didn't really
expect at all it looks strange my g4
looks like very good for me and we
cannot really go to d4 I think with the
bishop 94 captures in any way a 93 just
just should win the game 93 attacking
the Queen and g2 was check and then I
deform it's just the curtains and i'm
not sure what what this is what's the
IDM Knight d4 I can also take okay this
must be the right move maybe that's some
technical idea at this was the idea I
didn't think about this at all it seems
really weird to give up the bishop maybe
from maybe technically it is just
defined but
stategic Leah you would never give up
the bishop hmm alright still um it's
looking looking strange but dan needs to
be refuted still so how could I'm could
I approach this I mean one possibility
would be a bishop 86 just a very direct
plane intending to take III and take f4
and if you place g3 playing a 5 trying
to really punish wide maybe this is
possible so this needs to be M
considered um carefully though because
it's not necessary to play in this sharp
fashion because I can simply take you
three and play d4 and I'm just fine
maybe I loose upon but he's got so many
weaknesses it's no problem Bishop age 60
Sam yeah the much more ambitious move if
it works out it so it's it's great but
um okay what else is there if I've
instantly doesn't make any sense right
now there's a page 6 mm I'll just take
ND Fauria taking d for some simple end
and okay probably
yeah this it is interesting come on push
it to age 6 I'm down to three to seven
minutes and he's down to nine so not a
huge time disadvantage so on about any
move I take on III and take F F for
getting the pawn back with the big
center and just a big advantage so he
probably needs to play g3 and then he
five the only thing that might be
irritating him yeah this kind of moves
night moves or Bishop b5 still I thought
the sound this wouldn't really work Eve
5v5 looks got you mm yeah just e5 if I
he cannot take only 593 Bishop g5 wins
so it probably needs to take on G form I
should reform and then castles I could
take that on a form it's not so clear is
it better to first take on e3 and then
play e5s may be better right slicker not
a ganar threaten to take gathers must be
better
let's go up here and then in five yeah
this looks tricky now for white how do
you prevent it takes fyn Bishop takes g5
threatening to win a piece now and it's
all it's all a bit shaky yeah probably
you need to check out some some tactical
yeah some some weird stuff that might
might work technically on I mean a move
like Knight f3 or something it's just it
just lost um against good play we've got
two bishops and a big center you should
take I mean he must have some technical
idea now otherwise um it's it's pretty
much it's just resigns if you move the
the night back now or something
I don't see a good move really I don't
see a move no idea how he should keep
the sum together g3 and son yeah maybe
g3 as awful as it looks but maybe you
need to do that I can simply take them
f4 and play em okay if it's not outright
winning I can take f1 play rook e8
probably yeah and then Bishop g4 coming
yeah this is over yeah takes on f4 okie
eight and then Bishop g4 pinning the d2
now a bishop or bishop a success it's
basically the same he cannot play g3 and
if you cannot play g3 how does he how
does he not lose and tricky yeah maybe
I'm overlooking some kind of big
resource here but I don't see it looks
really terrible
yeah probably a Knight to g5 the move
before this was probably am not working
at all I'm not I'm not sure at all about
this position I mean it looks like i
have pretty good chances but it's a
quite technical i could easily
overlooked something but in the position
we have now i think it's pretty much
hopeless I don't see a move I mean a
really playable move this that still
keeps the positioner playable don't
don't really see it aha okay yeah
relatively speaking this is a good move
young he's right okay so i can take on
f4 with the pawn i could also check with
the rook which wouldn't be at too bad
hmm I don't know rook takes frm
threatened some group takes each form
immediately and winning outright I can
also take with the porn it's not bad now
but rook takes look some look somewhat
stronger rook takes h4 it's really a big
big a big threat okay if you place g3 um
yeah that's that's interesting maybe
just rookie form Oh ropa takes edge for
an hour
so once the house doesn't it yeah rib
cage which for Bishop takes g5 and the
Queen and the rook good thing Luke on
edge for hey was check them once at
least the peace and now yeah well
everything saying the rook on h1 was
check so he cannot dumb just capsule or
something I'd take on g5 and on some
funny move like I don't know 96 97 I can
I can probably just take a katek h1 was
checking me okay must be must be over
but this was was simply terrible after
after the c5 move here I think it's it's
over probably if you look at this with a
computer afterwards I will do this I'm
quickly after after the game is finished
I'm probably the computer will find some
miracle defense but for human terms it
looks looks terrible
Wow so i can i can just take now right
Bishop takes and time it's an extra
piece
yeah not much to to UM to talk about
it's just them an extra piece and what
seems to not really am yeah he doesn't
seem to want to resign though it
certainly a.m. yeah hopeless and with
almost five minutes some left on the
clock for me so I'm just taking here
right okay the quickest is probably to
try win on the B file at Bishop to f5 if
possible route be aid stuff like that
can could be a quick quick finish young
yeah Luke h1 he wants to get in at least
them I made threat I guess but them it's
not really a not really dangerous of
course and I can even play age five
yeah come on let's let's develop develop
this piece yeah now I have two should be
formed because the g two nite is pinned
and this also prevents rock h1 yeah very
nice meeting pattern now would be rook
p8 Queen a5 Queen takes c3 may don't be
one would be nice probably it will
prevent this but I can I can try dami
will play a queen f2 now probably now
that I'm threatening together to take on
d 2 and rugby too I mean everything's
the same it's resign resign a volume
Quinn a5 Quincy three would be nice be
takes will be one made because of the
pin the night we have fun made a funny
move might be was just thinking about
rook 2m 2f seven but ok it wouldn't
wouldn't work probably but them okay
Queen 85 maybe I can get this in itself
it's a fun fun idea so okay but I can
take be three year rugby three I can
take a bee queen a one mate
no counter come to something right white
resides yeah so a takes be this is made
yeah but let's let some have a brief
look at at this game how it how it went
down I think he really should should
develop I mean something like oh I did
this wrong I need to really take back
the moves yeah i'd really prefer to to
get something developed I'm not sure so
that after this he can play this with
the tempo probably I won't even take on
e5 but play something like this with
this idea getting this this back later
but this looks I don't know better to me
at least them than taking because now
I'm so um so up in development probably
it's still okay but it's not it's not
great I think and now I'm yeah now I
have a choice i played this interesting
with b6 this was also an idea but I
didn't really see how to continue after
that computer gives you five with with
an advantage already yeah it's certainly
not bad yeah computers right this is the
problem castles and then probably not
you for him didn't appreciate that
really we should d for Bishop age six
and then some it's critical yeah this is
good for black probably
okay but maybe six move from certainly
was okay and I think you really should
take it take it and try to play this
position at some it's certainly am
certainly not terrible for white this
year I should have compensation but
computer wants to play this move
interesting and here trying to repeat
with the position I can I can go here
even it's still on compensation I've got
all this open lines let's say this rook
here Queen yam doesn't have a good
square go here you go I have to reckon
with this this ideas it's its
compensation yeah okay but this I think
it's tricky one should you play now
computer actually wants to go Bishop see
one bag but this is certainly great for
black Queen d2 yeah and now it gets that
gets problematic the computer wants to
take on e3 immediately and then Bishop
h6 yeah maybe this is better yes he
gives Bishop b5 as the best move but
still with a big advantage for me this
is what you played and this year the
sluices yeah I'm okay this should be
five supposed to be better but still I
can take yeah we cannot they cannot take
hear something like this I've got always
this kind of stuff yeah and Quinn takes
Bishop takes yeah and now who cannot
show like just go here is queenie 6 i'm
sorry this one okay
so Queenie two and then probably this
move yeah okay I mean black black must
be you must be great here to bishops at
the center and it looks it looks it
looks bad this is not even feasible
rookie six white must castle and this
castle and then I can't just take it and
this is Sir and the 22 bishops yeah okay
the game will sound this and this is the
others lost ya computer agrees minus
three rook takes and will gauge foyer
and resigns yeah an interesting game
this Jew 685 idea paid off I think
really am after this probably white
should take on d5 I am I mean this is
not a mistake but I think it helps blood
to get in the c5 in one move to
understand what I'm talking about thus
there are lines like this um let's let's
get all all the way back d 5 is what I
played but there are also lines like
this here where black plays c5 later and
he takes two moves obviously c6 and c5 I
did the game I got in got this in in one
move and the center is immediately under
pressure here besides this which was a
bit sharper I could also take here and
trying to get pressure this way it also
shouldn't be too bad for black it's just
questionable if why should play F for
this kind of structure that weakens lots
of squares I'm especially considering
that I want a temple here this is quite
often air force normal but then the
position is more clothes and I haven't
won this tempo yeah thanks for watching